so new developments in the Jessie small
light case today Chicago Police have
released hundreds of documents related
to the alleged hate crime hoax by the
former Empire actor among the
revelations prosecutors told detectives
that they were working on a possible
plea deal with Smollett a month before
all 16 felony counts against him were
suddenly dropped the files also show
Smollett denied to police that the
brothers linked to the case were his
attackers citing their dark skin color
because he said that his attackers were
white and text reveal that Smollett
asked the brothers if they had contacts
at one point there's these text messages
between them looking for ecstasy or
cocaine once before the alleged attack
so clearly he was very familiar with
both of them at that point so you know
this is not going away and this is very
bad news for Kim Fox who was the
prosecutor who dropped this case to
everyone's shock Greg you know it's very
interesting to me that that this is like
people have dug their teeth in and I
think it's very good news for equal
justice know what it is I do think that
they underestimated the magnitude of the
hoax they looked at past hoaxes and
generally the media will cover the
incident but when the incident unravels
they tend to move on but because this
had taken a national the size of a
national story because of the maggots
and the Trump relationship it made
hiding this impossible so once it was
unraveling they I think they were trying
to do him a favor and sweep this under
the rug just a community-service pay a
fine and what happened was he couldn't
keep his mouth shut he couldn't keep his
end of the deal and he screwed himself I
do have I said this before he can
resurrect his career and make his life
better to come clean and actually
directly appeal to the people that he
demonized you know the there is a
potential especially I'm gonna you know
among Republicans and conservatives and
the religious do not underestimate the
amount of forgiveness that is out there
if he was to say look I wrongly smeared
you know these trucks you know and I
want to tell you like that would be
something that I would like to talk
about forgive like he could come clean
it's not conservatives it's Trump
backers
the magg ahead that's what you're saying
right what I say conservatives I don't
think that it's people who are repulsive
my chance for a guy to actually do
something right well you know that this
thing is so confused it's a big mess in
my mind yeah but I will say this I think
the guys lied I don't think there's much
doubt about it but I was surprised this
morning in terms of this dump Martha
because I didn't think there was much
new there I don't think there was much
news there it's it seems to me to be a
situation where cops see things
differently than prosecutors the cops
see that something happened here they
think he lied as I do the prosecutor
said you know what this isn't worth the
time the money and the effort to
prosecute this guy he's some big star
he's unlikely to ever do anything like
this again or commit any violent crime
let's make a deal and get out of here
but some people and I think it's because
of the politics behind it don't want to
let it go we didn't know he had a
previous conviction that was no sure we
knew no we did not we did not know that
we also didn't know there was this drug
connection between him and the brothers
home we also did only through leaks why
he was offered to pick these two out of
a lineup and he refused and we didn't
know either that the sweetheart deal was
in the process of becoming a sweetheart
deal from earlier on than we thought so
the whole thing was crooked from the
jump and like Greg had said before we
dodged a race war if you had seen the
video of two guys in maggots beating a
celebrity black gay actor on the streets
of Chicago this would have been like
wildfire and there would have been
violence across the country based on
their own
you think he's dr. King celebrities all
came out in support of him many of them
came out in support of him it was a
cause celeb and it was very embarrassing
for all of them when suddenly it turns
out that the story is not what everybody
thought it was it made me do very high
profile interviews with Robin Roberts
she was you know so worked up about
these guys he said I want that video
found so badly so that everyone can stop
saying that this is an alleged attack
people do not people I think the color
is irrelevant oh come on it's about look
this is about what Gregg's police
thought on the bus stop the police Jeep
ran in front of the bus with the mayor
and said oh yeah yeah we know we know
this we know that you know what they
should have waited that you should not
persecute in the underlying police he
also smeared the brothers and now that
you have the situation where the city is
out of the money for the investigations
that went forward and he got away with
only paying the $10,000 if he had kept
his mouth shut the show might still be
going on remember because all of the
actors were like well we've want the
show to continue but because it became
got so far out of control they couldn't
do that but now these the brothers are
having to sue him about and the the
lawyers smollett's lawyers because they
can't figure out a way to make a living
so he's like basically like there's a
trail of destruction behind this guy and
that's why it makes the brothers want to
work for waters world there's two slots
open producers well you're welcome there
don't sell coke and ecstasy anymore okay
never mind
[Laughter]